hello and welcome you stay at home and
enjoy s ession um some games
I'm playin the tournament oh let's play
a couple of games
eating times I know nowadays
sorry but a GM opponent
cannot at the currently disabled
yeah I'm the leeches note is very very
high
um
[Music]
yeah this is why
currently cannot to watch the both our
page
brenn mastery
in any case got a London system buying
this in a very
mystic wavy of them
hence position our to a
um to UM arrow in structure
until you call it a reversed
first outfit
it
and have seemed
yet chiming to me because you cannot
hold the pawn so he's basically saying
that we'll get enough play
then the various hints
which could be true
anyway I'm committed to this wait
is Rookie one
just definitely
enough playful white tea will probably
get them a pin sorry
or coffee somehow hit my protein
uncomfortable way
now it's a little bit
okay now
[Music]
and take on c6 and 25 there's no way
prevented
again I'm giving up then or he's giving
up the two bishops for the two knights
and hopefully this should be fine I
think it should actually
I wonder how I should get back
um
[Music]
you
think if I every six
six porn really matter that much
maybe a
earlier
it will be eight I think I'm fine
right make a mass mall
ruction advantage but
don't think you can
but
you
see
or no mean possible but
and much
you
I will take some moments too
like always some move to get back here
under if the
maybe six seven
look at this
urgh
you
Oh
five and now the thing is I have g5g for
like a minority attack
Prime
yeah this is the thing I was a bit
worried about that but I wanted to code
and check me and then I cannot good
okay
going to play Paso
exit a check on the second and then I
have the danger dangerously on okay
sticks key five you can f h6 I don't
care have to play actively
Hosting em
like technical fireworks but
Bravo
and
[Music]
oh it says police is better for black
it's not possible to be better for white
actively picking I might miss play it
and screw it up but
definitely not name problem
Dave
you
you boys checking me relief making
and just check him for draw
and ads are really a kind of a chicken
dessert
a little bit concerned about the time
[Music]
you
because I have
you
I don't think I'm running any
risk in terms of the position
I'm risk him
you
there's a way to playful
right
you
and just
YUM of to say I think I probably had
something but I'm going to look at this
after the rematch I'm happy to have a
Grand Master here so let's play someone
interesting why not
billion
you
yeah this I have covered in simple
one-year form 1890 of six is interesting
move but I am
so knowledgeable about it so going to
play this which is a bit lame Harrison
but
after we were seen with white
eating a very solid way of playing
you
take on you
the same moment
you
it's a movement
you
I'd have six always have to check this
off
yeah like mr. chickens made but not
getting them
but now I ever had two nights on the f6
square this this would be it would be
quite good
um okay so take
it's a bit funny that I have to i'd say
against two bishops because ways
records for such a addict the night CI
doing a good job
not so easily opening of the position
of the station
you
I would like to open up I love us
[Music]
book
I
five
form
you
f queen h2 for Queen trade but that is a
really lame decision
I have Queen g3 but I'm not quite sure
what my next planners
you know
you
it's what it is okay Jade is dangerous
just very dangerous the Queen on age
five and so on
you
that is
you ate correcting
you
now
and of miracle fortress
that requires definite head player black
you
a lot totally simple em Jim
[Music]
make headway but and
[Music]
you
the night should
you
and yeah
you
have to sit
you
95 but
barking time
almost but
you
a great frame to take it reasonable
you
ready whoo
you
who that was
thought
or they have 95 which they don't have
I'd age who is going to put it
you
some vague chances or if I get in c4 and
Knight to f3 for example
most of Porter's
you
all right
a very weird way house
nation
I just donated the bishop somehow
it
you
how they were lucky draw we have to
fight I'm very lucky but hey so
do it again
you
yeah
allas
85 though
you
it is the various away by this position
but it's definitely feasible ship c4 and
then a three before stuff like that um
not really
don't really buy that white should be
better here this husband
claimed
Larry Kaufman
I don't I don't really think that way
engines are confirmed or the engines
also give quite a small advantage
I don't quite buy that particular for
human
Teek maybe I can take it
ship c6s 93
and now do we go 94 here
habla okay
yeah why not
cannot be great on it seven and if XC
eggs
you
okay
five
cannot simply
you
- bid weakening five so you have to
check if
what about f 4 f 4 f 3 is that totally
unreasonable
it is a little bit unreasonable
but
this is a bit more interesting compared
to some other kind of because there is
no night this is no night it could come
come to warm
a
you
believe oh yeah here's silly
you
a bit of an annoying
or exit it takes win doesn't have many
moves
okay so he's preparing bishop to read
it's not just preparing me but to play
it but
ticking
you
back in position
you
now
you
and make it draw right
you
I know if I can
I just have 30 seconds
you
would be objectively riskier Inc better
I just don't have time
yeah I know it's a chicken decision you
can decision but it's also fun to play
Twitter oh yeah okay so
you
yes we can if you know out
this is the most amazing baby from that
big
the one that's and to forget
it's all in the green book behind me
that you can see now
um hey so yeah
you
Iria of course
Oh each three
you
this is generally very useful here d5
to ever this is the right moment to do
it
you
levels
dynamics but okay
talking about the guru felt and also I'm
opening
you
don't have a really you
you
and take with the bishop
I get it
on the a3 night to the impressions
way and
get rid of the nice
you
ship takes I didn't like to take with
the bishop then take one be seven that
that looks extremely loose and there is
ninety-five stuff so on
the moment I take on deform
is Bishop and night add more scope
this has to be considered carefully on
that
now there's any serious pressure on it
so maybe he just has to take on
at least it's a I can enter
what take one of three also desirable to
that
you
I am the note still not
III to see for something like that would
definitely be
which to to manage
and night
you
quick to a3 I would definitely like to
give it
you
eggs on age who have rook e1
which
you
should really should go to a three that
would be yes
a way to get down
you
well this is not an ideal square
you
in Gabon
[Music]
you
a
or
initech one mover but early put any
serious pressure on
you
it is it or the Queen back for the mode
you know cheek because of the check
and black
the bishop on a1 is not a good piece
would be interesting to check
when the position started to shift in
blacks favor because
[Music]
at the beginning I was completely okay
of course
and probably rather better
I think the whole line is favorable for
wide action
any finally Bishop a3
you
getting in though
it's still not totally over here
6b
you
hello k97 beep hangs
you
winning us
you
it's incremental
you
a key
you
was at some moment I definitely was
worse or thing
you
quite believe me in winning this
you
and take time you Adam
it's not the quickest way to win but
now I could take
it
and as no need to rush this
you
right order I want to attack g6 of
course
you
nowhere to go
setback
you
I didn't do it in the fastest way I know
- just do it reliably
now there was a funny match redraws and
i won the final game we didn't have any
analysis and we can at now so we start
with this one
and
I thought yeah I should be a little bit
better
the engine is confirming that but the
the game didn't show it so I had some
issues in the game
oh here
don't wants to leave
isn't totally dislike my youtuber a form
this is not too bad that and probably
here okay one is good yeah
a concept like that is certainly
something you can find but not so in a
blitz game me
okay so this
yeah it's all
normal position at that scene it was a
bit of a naive move anyway win c4 is
better huh
probably play some Wii and then the
computer thinks I'm better probably
because of the static advantage of the
protective on
okay so this
how the game is better
it's a porn after all but then he
somehow lost the plot
around here the bishop now is activated
here I'm burning
or incidental
my my my technical play wasn't the best
but it was enough
very difficult to switch this up
one winning idea in such a position is
simply to sacrifice on f7 and to get a
winning King and pawn ending I could
have done that at some point here this
wins but a map is up I mean you can
simply in an increment game and simply
take your time slowly
right forward in this rook g47 wins here
that was a was a stupid idea
but you can always just go back and
correct your mistake yeah I saw that
this is going to be easy conversion okay
now we whoops
look at my games ash
it's too bad
and in the history we give you this
yeah so that does work and jump to this
game this way look into the analysis
this was the first game when he played
this early 95 they decided to take him
yes so we got this
yeah we had the ending which I felt was
not equal that was it
you
yeah I think at some point I had an
advantage which I couldn't quite find
how
the later ending
around here I had something g4 didn't
like efore was happened
our distinct stuffy or and III wasn't or
seems too
nice whoo just fighting fighting for
those on set if it takes I probably
haven't
check and fe3 and deform it would have
been a strong opportunity
I didn't have much time so I decided to
take but I also thought I'm better here
it
maybe that wasn't the case
now here the engine
basically as it's wrong
if we did a little bit of a back end
and play look see we can wind up on
yeah
you cannot do this be also win step on
it some other way
I can simply take and then go behind
upon that's true I had some chances
there okay it was a draw we also had
now this
just said work again me
um
you
hmm not sure it's a little bit of a pain
at the moment because they had to
disable
and to disable some of the features
maybe this
no I don't know how how I get there mmm
bit of a pain I would have looked at the
other game sort of like to look at the
other games it was interesting
just way to have an idea
yeah beg on and a managed to retrieve
this from my browser history but we need
to do is life um so here um that was the
my chicken draw where should probably
continue
so this
there was a funny variation I like 93
watch very much um okay so this 94
take whatever man five and now f4 is an
interesting decision I don't know
think it's it's it's an interesting
we played Queen f3 now ng5 it wants to
quake
or prophylactic
see it I'm mostly interested in the end
if I would have played on norm
purely iting perspective I should employ
common difficult at
time was a little bit you know already
so the engine only gives me all
advantage thing
like a win I wasn't sure I did was
possible that maybe there was something
wants to go see form
[Music]
chicken
I would have continued
this looks better hope like but it
doesn't look like
it was a huge mislead
okay and then we had this one where I
was definitely struggling
yeah this is we have this we had
disposition and
here played D 3 is also neither 6 check
which is an interesting alternative but
this is involving this particular line
you have to sacrifice the Queen and this
is interesting white but I never studied
it in much detail but I felt it didn't
fit into my keep it simple book and this
is why I played d3 which is what I have
in the book
and I thought this is nothing special
here it's like a normal position but
then he started to slowly or claim in
debatable him what I did here but
student s over here
oh it seems that here I'm okay again is
the computers on seeing much
each I didn't have a clear idea what to
do
maybe c4 was right him if he has to take
it is definitely
this wasn't good
this is
okay I just see I have this idea
you know he cannot just do whatever
you
I should have gone been aged to
immediately and here it hit me that rook
h8 is going to be very very dangerous
and then and ok let's trade the Queen's
but here I'm definitely worse absolutely
worse
- man bomb and now g3 is a mistake
I have to grovel in some other way
it says IG Ives if I can get one of the
bishops it is okay think and I
and then this is two about equal it's
it's difficult to really be worse in
this position if you are precise but I
didn't manage to do that
so this pawn was lost and yeah you can
just try to hang on it was just like a
lucky
I think you did a pretty good conversion
I was really lucky here g4 turned out
well but my main issue was I wish is
blind I somehow thought I have this and
I get it back which is pretty
nonsensical and this is losing due to g3
getting into King and pawn ending
immediately
so I had to do this and this is a win
but he has to do it right so you have
six wins and this is
Wow
okay ug just runs here right okay now
but but I think the way it went it was
still losing honey was I didn't play in
the best possible way and I'd accept
you
I mean he's not risking anything with
this move I'm not sure it was probably a
blunder didn't do it on purpose
giving up the the bishop because these
King is just entering here and I'm
actually a little bit surprised that Y
can draw you but computer is right here
for sure I mean just calculates in the
bitter end
okay but I took here and this is
probably lost
salude raw honey I mean this should be 2
is given as a small edge form like by
the engine but I can go c4 and that is
wrong
not really that's totally ed here and
this is a fortress doesn't really matter
that D has a c6
you
it's just about holding
poor lucky
you
just works edge this funny
crazy I was super lucky this is the kind
of game I would like I would really be
like ah my opponent is such a clown yeah
drawing this
Wow okay a very interesting match for
more interesting games I hope you
enjoyed this thanks for watching